[Music]
uh this is like my favorite subject you
know i spent like 15 years of my life
building uis
in the traditional event handler way it
just felt so so hard
that it was almost offensive to me you
know like
that i should need to use every single
ounce of my brain power to hold in my
head this
pretty small dialogue in a windows app
you know
like it's not the most complicated thing
in the world and yet
i am straining all of my
you know brain cells
uh to make sure that all these
relationships are correct seems like
everything you add makes it
exponentially more complicated that's
exactly right all non-trivial software
this is the number one problem
how do we manage the complexity because
everything we add has the potential to
interact with everything else so what i
want to say about this reactive graph
issue where you start out with an input
and an output right naughty not even a
reactive in the middle just input output
multiple inputs to one output multiple
outputs to one input sure like all of
that is pretty understandable and then
you add one or two reactive calculations
in the middle but it doesn't take much
for that to start becoming
very crazy looking especially when you
have
multiple levels of reactive calculations
i think like a most important thing to
understand
is that you're not supposed to
understand the whole graph the goal is
not to create a graph that you look at
and say oh that's definitely right think
of this as the same exact thing
with functions in a normal piece of
software or normal package
which functions call which other
functions and you could draw a graph
with that right you can draw a function
called graph and and people do like
their software that that does that for
you right it helps helps you make those
connections the goal is never
to be able to look at that entire
graph of functions pointing at each
other and be like oh yep that's right
you know like
that's not the point if your software is
well written
the point is to be able to look at any
one node
any one node in that graph and prove to
yourself that that node is correct to
look at one output
and just look at the things that are
calling into that output
it just one level right like don't go
beyond the arrows that are going
directly into that output
and say are those correct
and if the answer is yes then you can
move on
you can move on to look at each of the
other nodes in the graph
so the point is not to be able to reason
globally the point is to be able to
reason locally this is exactly the same
thing
that we say about functions right when
you write a function
the goal is not to be able to take
the entire rest of your code base that
might
indirectly or directly call or be called
by a function that's under a question
the goal is to be able to look at this
function
and to be able to confidently say
if the functions that this calls are
written correctly then this logic is
correct
so you need to be able to look at this
function and reason about just this
function in isolation
now you might be wrong like you might be
assuming that those other functions are
written correctly and that might not be
true but that problem is a much better
problem to have to tackle than the
possibility that all those functions are
correctly written and you still don't
know if your code is correct because not
only do you have to know that they're
correct but you have to know about
really subtle interactions that those
functions have with each other with
reactivity
this is a way that that same quality of
i can look at a small piece of code and
just by knowing that
the
reactives that are being called if those
just assume that those are
going to execute at the right time then
this is going to execute at the right
time if there's something that i'm
calling and i don't want to update when
it updates then i need to know to call
isolate around that uh so not calling
isolate when i don't want
a reactive relationship that would be a
bug in this code right
but if i don't have that bug if
i
my relationship with my immediate things
that i depend on
is correct
then i'm satisfied that this piece of
code is correct and now i can go look at
another piece of code and make sure that
it's correct the bottom line being if
you have an app that's written
out of 10 such pieces of code
then you have to make sure that 10
pieces of code are correct
and if you add an 11 piece of code you
have to make sure that 11th piece of
code is correct
as opposed to having to make sure that
each piece of code and all of the
possible interactions it could ever have
with any of the rest of the pieces like
now that's not 10 things you need to
check it's like 10 factorial or
something like that right or
i don't know what the what the what the
map is but um it is something that's
certainly non-linear in terms of each
additional thing you add you now have to
check all these all the possible things
that it could interact with oh my gosh
i'm going to add a new thing and it's
going to be so complicated to know
whether this is going to blow up
something that you know i already have
that was the world that we lived in
before reactivity when it came to
writing interactive uis this might go
nowhere but i think when people think
about the lego analogy which like that
comes up a lot when you talk about
components and software right like a lot
of people think of them as like legos at
a high level you tend to think oh i want
the ability to snap anything
anything should be able to snap to
anything else right i just want to take
two software components and snap them
together i don't get that much pushback
on reactivity like oh why didn't you do
reactivity this way like there just has
not been that much of it i think because
it's sufficiently
complicated that it's like it's not the
most natural thing to bike shed on
but modules were like the opposite like
everybody's got an opinion on modules
and
i mean for
most of the life of shiny people have
had opinions on why i didn't do it the
right way you know
and and the right way meaning something
so different to every person
um
but one really common
refrain was basically people don't like
that you have to pass in like if you if
you have something like a module that
takes some kind of input that needs to
be provided from somewhere else in the
app
right like you've got a module that does
something with a data frame but it
doesn't itself want to have any opinion
about
what that data frame is or where it came
from or how it's specified right like it
wants to specialize just on some output
or whatever how do you communicate with
that module how do you tell it this is
the
data frame you should use and here's
when it changes
and the way that works in shiny modules
is when you define the module you take
that data frame as a input
you take a reactive
uh calculation as an input a lot of
people push back on that and they're
like
i don't want to have all these
things that i'm passing into you know
this lego brick right like why can't all
lego bricks just look the same right i
don't want to pass in
these four arguments that it needs i
just want to give it
a dictionary how about that every module
just takes a dictionary and then you
just have to put the right things in the
dictionary
and then
like look how clean the code is for
snapping together all these legos i just
make a dictionary put some stuff in it
and then everybody gets the dictionary
and oh i can use the dictionary
dictionary for both input and output not
only can i get data frames out of it or
other you know reactive things i can
also push values into it and then other
modules can consume it and look how easy
it is to snap these legos together right
this is where it's like
it's not enough that the legos go
together they have to go together
correctly right
so lego minifigs have heads and torsos
and legs right you can't put a head on
the legs directly like they have to they
only connect one
way
and those connections are obvious with a
lot of component components it's
actually more like that
like you don't want legos that will snap
together whether they belong together or
not
you actually want it to be very obvious
that this thing needs to connect with
something that's like this it's more
like puzzle pieces so people arguing for
oh let me just have a dictionary that i
pass in what they're really saying is
like
oh it's so annoying putting together
this puzzle with all the pieces are all
jagged wouldn't it be easier if they
were all just squares like
let me make this you know put together
this 500 piece puzzle but it'll be so
much easier if they're all just squares
you know
um it is actually you're actually making
it so much harder right because
that problem still exists
like you still need to make sure that
that
data frame that you need is provided to
you
um it's just now provided in a very
hidden way that you have to go and speak
out that's not obvious so you've removed
the signal of how these things connect
you've removed these sort of weirdly
shaped borders and replace them with
flat borders even though they can really
still only connect in one way if that
makes sense
so again just another example of that
principle of
small pieces that we can locally reason
about and then combine them in reliable
ways
and when we have just like these
dictionaries that we pass around it's
removing
that part of like we need to be able to
combine these reliably
there's so many different ways
i want to answer this question certainly
between building the front end and the
back end i don't think there's a right
order if what is going to get you
excited about the project
enough to sort of build that momentum is
that you have this cool ui concept in
mind and or that just motivates you to
look at something concrete and see it
sort of one piece after another light up
absolutely go go crazy with the ui first
you know um i don't think there's
anything wrong with that if instead like
you you really you know have some kind
of
r code on the server that you're really
excited to see
you know
come to life for the first time and that
is going to be what excites you and
propels you through the rest of the
project you know i don't think that
there is a wrong or wrong way to do it
like if you want to end up with
this a bunch of like well-named
well-reasoned nicely factored reactives
and outputs and whatever is that
something you sort of do on a whiteboard
first um and then sort of stub each one
out and make it so or is it more
something that you just start coding and
then extract out the things that you
need again i don't think there's a wrong
way to do it but
i would draw a direct analogy
to
when you're writing either a package or
maybe a complicated script when and how
do you introduce functions because it's
exactly the same process that applies
here as well i think uh maybe there's
it's a little bit more urgent because
like it's not going to react unless you
find somewhere to park this code that is
you know reactive um
so in that sense yeah you are going to
be forced to confront it but
some people might
write straight line code that's you know
i'm just going to get this thing working
and i get the answer i want and then let
me take a step back and see where are
opportunities to refactor and turn into
functions i think that's probably the
most common right uh and and for that
reason
you might go
a long time without ever learning how to
write functions if
if your job is more about finding that
answer the one time and then moving on
so i would call that sort of like a
bottom-up approach right you've got the
logic and then now you're trying to
extract structure out of it i think
that's probably the more common
way people think their brains work
i happen to be the other way whereas i
will start with if i could wave a magic
wand and have whatever functions i need
to exist
if they could exist what a little piece
of code would i write that would solve
the problem that i have here so for some
really simple example i might say
i want i'm going to waive my magic wand
and say load dataset remove outliers and
clean maybe that's another function
and then let me you know generate
a set of outputs uh using these two
functions that i wish existed
and i will just call them even though
they don't exist and then i will stub
them out so that's working exactly the
opposite way like i'm calling functions
that don't exist and then each of those
functions is potentially going to call
functions that don't exist until
eventually they start calling functions
that exist right
um and then you basically create a
skeleton for the structure first and
then fill out you know go back and fill
out all the pieces if you can get to
this place either way of small
components that you can individually
reason about and combine them reliably
that's ultimately what matters
um
so yeah in in this in this second like
the top-down way where you write you
call the functions that you wish existed
making sure that that
their functions that
you want to be
well functional right you tend to want
them not to use global state if you can
help it
i guess in the python world it might be
classes that you wish existed you you
knew up an object that doesn't exist yet
you call methods that don't exist um and
then you can go back and and fill those
things out it is harder to do the top
down if it's
an unfamiliar domain like i think the
more speculative and the more like
oh my gosh how is this even going to
work the harder it is to go that sort of
top-down approach
so
i'll sometimes go the top-down approach
until i realize oh i'm way out over my
skis here i don't actually know how this
technology works
let me go back and do a bunch of
bottom-up experiments and sort of
just work with these libraries i had
never worked with or this kind of data
that i've never seen before
and
once you start to get a sense of
confidence about how
how the problem is going to be solved
then i might you know
switch over to okay let me go back to
this approach of of top down so the same
thing i think for
shiny apps i tend to think top down so
if i'm looking at a you know dashboard
that i want to build and it's going to
have these four inputs i think
what data am i going to need for that
right um oh i'm going to have to do a
bunch of aggregations in order to get
that data do i also need to access the
unaggregated data for other things in
the app well if so then i really want to
make sure
that those are both things that are
exposed as
you know not functions in this case but
reactive uh calculations and then i
i feel like the in the relationship
between the inputs and the reactive
calculations i tend not to even think
about that at all like that just sort of
happens i call the things that i need
and then they end up depending on them
unless there's some very specific reason
like you know i'm gonna use this
slider input to inform this calculation
but not till this button is pressed okay
fine then you use an event you know for
that um i can't relate sometimes when
people say to me like oh there's all
these like problems with my reactivity
and i don't i have a really hard time
keeping track
of what
inputs are being referenced by what
reactives i'm sort of like
why do you need to keep track like it's
not about keeping track of the global
graph so it's really about each
individual reactive only accessing the
things that it needs that's the way i
approach it